CYNTHIA THOMAS: Hi.
This is Cynthia Thomas.
I'm a networking
specialist at Google Cloud.
Welcome back to "What's
New in Networking."
Today, we're going
to talk about Anthos
and compute networking
launches, so stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's start with Kubernetes.
As more enterprises
adopt Kubernetes,
new requirements are coming up
around multicloud, security,
and visiblity.
And new technologies,
like Service Mesh,
demand more customizations
of the underlying Kubernetes
layer.
These requirements all need a
more programmable data plane
that can do Kubernetes-aware
networking without sacrificing
performance.
I'm pleased to introduce
to you Dataplane V2.
Dataplane V2 is an opinionated
data plane for GKE and Anthos
clusters, and it's
been optimized
for Kubernetes networking.
Dataplane V2 is
implemented with EBPF--
Extended Berkeley Packet Filter.
This handles network
packets in the kernel
by configuring the data plane
using Kubernetes-specific
metadata.
Dataplane V2 brings several
advantages to your deployments.
From a security and
operations perspective,
you have native
Kubernetes network policy
and logging without the need
for a third-party add-on.
Network policy logging lets you
monitor how your policies are
enforcing traffic.
That way, you can see
allowed and denied
network connections in
the Cloud Logging Console
to audit and
troubleshoot policies.
Dataplane V2 also lends well
to large environments for scale
without the need for
a qproxy nor iptables
for service routing.
Finally, the big
thing Dataplane V2
brings to your
multifaceted environments
is consistency across
environment types--
GKE, Anthos vSphere, and
Anthos on bare metal.
With Dataplane V2,
you can quickly
identify abnormal
traffic patterns
and spot irregular
network activity.
Finally, let's talk
about Google Virtual NIC,
or gVNIC for short.
It's a virtual network
interface designed specifically
for Google Compute Engine.
Previously, VMs that
ran on Compute Engine
used a virtual network interface
based on the Virtio spec.
For better networking
performance
and to support
additional features,
Google uses gVNIC as its default
virtual network interface.
GVNIC supports higher
network bandwidths,
such as 50 to 100
gigabits a second.
These can be used for
distributed workloads on VMs
that have attached GPUs.
If you want to use gVNICs, you
can use it on a supported OS
or on an unsupported OS by
manually installing the drivers
for Linux or Windows.
And that's our update for
Anthos and compute networking.
Check out the links
below for more details
on these new features.
Join us next time for
"What's New in Networking."
[MUSIC PLAYING]